good morning believe nation today's
message is seize the opportunities over
to you Shonda Rhimes TV I think I spent
a lot of time and a lot of people spend
a lot of time thinking of all the things
they want to do and talking about it but
the idea that you're not actually doing
anything to get to where you want to go
you're waiting for some sort of big
magical moment or some door to open or
some I don't know some interesting
illuminating thing to happen is very
different from the hard day to day
slogging through step by step I'm going
to climb this ladder here's an
opportunity i'm going to run for it any
little small moment oh they want me know
i want to be a writer somebody what's
going to be an intern at third
production company i will go do that
somebody wants me to go you know work at
this job I will do that oh I'm gonna go
work at this sort of awful job because
it's going to pay the bill so i can
write at night well i'm going to do that
because that's a way to get where I want
to go people to want to do those things
because I think that they're waiting for
the big break and I think that hard work
and being a doer and taking every
opportunity that comes your way whether
or not it seems like the most amazing
one is the way to go I think people are
too afraid often to take the first step
and they want to have the perfect first
step and until they find it they don't
think any action where you need to
understand that there is no one perfect
right step no matter how much time you
spend planning and preparing and
dedicating your time to it until you
actually take that first to have nothing
matters yet and perfectionism kills so
many businesses before they even start
because you never actually take that
first step where the best thing to do is
take a step if it didn't work course
correct fix it take another step in
another step in another step so that you
make progress and build momentum towards
your goal in the time that you spend
thinking about what the perfect first
step is somebody else is early taking 50
steps forward and so much better than
the inaction is taking any kind of
action now I'm not saying go out and
take take out a huge
mortgage on your house or go deep into
debt or take some big risky decision
start small in every single business
there is no one perfect thing that you
need to do they've all been different
whether it's Microsoft or Google or Nike
or Apple or whatever company will look
at whatever their first step was it was
all different and so understand that
your first step is just one of a million
that you're going to have to take and
none of them are going to be perfect so
just start and then make next one better
and the next one better and the next one
better seize the opportunities that you
have in front of you instead of waiting
for the perfect one to calm because that
perfect one is not there you have to go
out and create it for yourself by taking
those steps so the question day today is
what is holding you back from taking the
next step in your business leave in the
comments below I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Christian Sharkey Christian
thank you so much you're buying my book
really means a lot to me those you
watching you want a chance at a shadow
in the future video make sure to pick up
a copy of the book and email in your
receipts will keep track thank you guys
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of its best oh
wait spray so give me